soir je me suis tapé un petit 2 km 5 de
kayak au milieu du pertuis avec tous les
courants aujourd'hui j'ai infiltré Fort
Boyard nous avons les costumes des
maîtres du temps juste là et nous avons
surtout leur masque là petite vigie du
Père Fouras
et franchement c'est assez épatant on
arrivait à la fauverie et c'est très con
à dire mais directement ça sent le fauve
quoi tout ça je suis sûr que c'est du
toc j'ai pas de checker
c'est que du toc et franchement je tire
mon chapeau à tout ce qui est
accessoiriste décorateur parce que quand
tu vois la gueule des décors en vrai tu
te dis waouh c'est chaud mec
non mais moi je comprends que la société
de production décide de l'attaquer en
justice ce garçon évidemment il ne veut
arrêter d'attaquer tout le monde
il est monté sur le fort illégalement il
a il a traversé de nuit il est monté
de mettre de d'attaquer tout le monde
mais qu'est-ce qui vous arrive Cyril
alors les gens rentre chez les gens
alors
arrête un peu mais qui vous arrive
il va pas revenir ça y est on va aller
l'attaquer on va à une société comme la
nôtre on va l'attaquer sur gala parce
que c'est nous les autres
conseils
il faut juste renforcer la sécurité
exactement
à la fin de la vidéo en fait il dit bon
bah voilà j'espère que vous n'allez pas
voilà porter plainte contre moi en tout
cas c'est un lieu magnifique j'ai
vraiment réalisé un rêve c'est quelqu'un
qui est fan et puis il faut pas oublier
que l'urbex c'est rentrer dans des lieux
qui bien sûr
il faut arrêter les mecs les vieux là
qui disent des conneries
la vidéo
Delphine qui travaille dessus elle est
pas choquée non et moi quand j'ai vu
cette vidéo j'ai trouvé ça mignon
j'espère que vous allez pas porter
plainte contre lui parce que le mec en
fait il est juste fan il a rien
elle est cool sa vidéo
franchement il faut arrêter d'attaquer
tout le monde en attaque à colentes on
attaque le gars de Fort-Boyard on va
attaquer quoi maintenant de leur mot
parce que voilà
c'est très bien ce que je veux dire
ranger ta chambre déjà moi j'ai adoré la
vidéo on voit tellement de gens sur
Internet qui sont prêts à n'importe quoi
pour faire le buzz à violent avec
négatif là c'est bienveillant c'est
juste un fan qui fait un kiffe mais
l'autorisation de quoi c'est même pas ça
n'appartient même pas la société de
production ça appartient à la région
Fort Boyard en plus
il rend service à l'émission il fait
visiter les coulisses du programme ça
fait des centres des malades
Benaim avec tout le respect que j'ai
pour vous vous dites n'importe quoi tu
n'as pas de respect pour lui tu n'as pas
de respect pour elle je n'ai aucun
respect pour vous mais
il fait du journalisme c'est du
journaliste citoyen
ne vous mêlez pas n'essayez pas votre
copine elle a besoin dans la sauce
il n'a pas pu
que vous étiez dans votre jeunesse vous
avez le droit d'entrer quelque part
quand vous ne pouvez pas entrer en
présentant votre car vous dites alors
il a fait du journalisme vous la
détestez vous détestez les manières et
là doré
il a pas mis 50 personnes au chômage
c'est quand on ne peut pas c'est quand
on ne peut pas
attaquer un petit mec comme ça un gros
groupe comme moi
il faut pas porter plainte faut pas faut
pas attaquer la marque volontaire
et par la loi des journalistes
alors aussi
de l'investigation des images mille fois
maintenant quand on voit après il y a
une femme qui vous montrent des suceurs
en plus votre marque il est en train de
dire c'est du carton
slip c'était du carton patte
un peu non on les laisse Delphine on
tire au pire déposer plainte pour donner
l'exemple et pour que d'autres personnes
ne le fassent pas parce qu'elle a en
fait on peut même se faire très mal et
puis ensuite
donc voilà déposer plainte pour dire ok
ne le faites plus mais en revanche
j'espère qu'il aura pas quelque chose de
grave
on sait pas aujourd'hui
la défense Fort Boyard elle est assez
minable parce qu'elle dit oui on a eu
peur qu'il ait eu un accident parce
qu'on peut pas et on peut pas joindre
par téléphone et s'il était tombé et
qu'il aurait eu un accident à ce
moment-là on pouvait pas le joindre
en regardant cette émission qui ont 10
ans qu'on pas envie que leur monde
est un peu toi tu es toujours du côté
des producteurs c'est des producteurs
mais si tu es toujours des côtés des
puissants d'un [ __ ] voilà alors ça oui
mais ça
ça n'a rien à voir avec cette chaîne
moi je supporte pas les gens qui font
des procès à tout va non mais c'est
insupportable non franchement vas-y tu
appelles le mec tu lui dis voilà je vais
te [ __ ] ta mère
tu lui dis ouais arrête vas-y tu as
déconné on se voit il veut venir
d'ailleurs demain il veut venir demain
et je lui ai je vais le défendre et vous
allez voir je vous le dis non et moi
quand j'ai un problème avec un mec je
l'appelle je vais le voir gentiment
voilà
mais là des mecs qui font des process
comme il y a un animateur il me fait un
procès là Monsieur il dit dénigrement ou
je sais pas quoi
j'y viens me voir on se voit au pire des
cas où on prend un verre et puis si ça
se passe mal je mets une tarte voilà
c'est tout voilà et puis c'est tout et
puis après on passe à autre chose c'est
là et puis on s'embrasse voilà c'est
tout